so you've been in it pretty open about
your hearing loss and tell everybody
that doesn't know what happened I've
been diagnosed with thing called
Meniere's disease and I was diagnosed
like thirty thirty years ago I lost my
right ear I had bouts of vertigo and
lost my hearing in my right ear about 30
years ago I lost 80% of it and I lived
existed on one ear for you know most of
this time and then two years ago two
years in a month I lost my left ear and
now although it fluctuates occasionally
which gives me hope yeah it's it's
really bad most of the time and the
worst part is I can't hear music as a
musician or the music is so much harder
to listen to than speech I can hear
speech a little bit with hearing aids I
wear hearing aids and all that and I can
Bluetooth through my phone and all that
but music the real problem is on my left
side the lower frequencies just fall off
the cliff and I have resonance or
distortion so I can't hear like a bass
part that would go ball bow-bow bow-bow
goes like it's a blown speaker yeah I
went to a famous ent guy when I first
had it I think and he said well he looks
at me just get used to it you know and I
want to lost the one ear I said you're
kidding me I said I'm a musician I'm
worried about he's just look Brian
Wilson had one ear Jimi Hendrix had one
ear the guy said I have one ear and I'm
in a barbershop quartet I said really I
love that you probably did that guy you
needed that guy in that moment I did
yeah just so it's like okay I'm gonna
crawl out of this this is not what I
wanted not good for mixing records
stereo you don't subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going